a meeting between the investigator and
her subject now a war of words over who
arranged it is boris johnson off the
hook we know the findings of sue gray's
report into lockdown breaking parties
were not discussed with boris johnson
but opposition parties say we now need
more detail to maintain confidence in
the inquiry so we need to hear quite
clearly who called the meeting and why
when was it held and what was discussed
there are differences of opinion right
now in the cabinet office and in downing
street between what what went on in that
meeting so we just need to have full
transparency and in all of this process
i think the whole country is saying that
we should have transparency so where are
we on friday afternoon sky news revealed
that sue gray and boris johnson had met
but the question of who called the
meeting was disputed by the evening
other news outlets were reporting it was
sue gray that had asked for the meeting
quoting a senior government source but a
spokesman for sue gray then denied that
account saying it wasn't accurate
in response a downing street source said
the prime minister did not request the
meeting but left open the possibility
that someone else in number 10 did who
requested the meeting matters because it
influences how much credibility we
should give to accusations that the
prime minister tried to meddle in this
investigation now those around boris
johnson firmly deny that but days from
the publication of this report it's
nothing short of remarkable that sue
gray's team has felt the need to
publicly question the truthfulness of
claims coming from within the government
are you worried about the sugree report
prime minister in wales yesterday boris
johnson wasn't keen to talk about
partygate he'll hope the publication of
the sugree report next week puts the
issue to bed accusations of a stitch up
risk prolonging the pain sue grey uh you
know is writing an independent uh report
none of us have seen it and it's uh down
to grey to release that report when
she's ready and i think if you look at
the initial report uh she was um you
know very very robust in that and we
would expect a similar a robust report
when when she does publish it
we know the law was broken repeatedly
here while the country was locked down
sue grey's report will give us more
detail about how and why it happened a
briefing war ahead of that is in no
one's interests but the fact it's
happening anyway
shows how keen both sides are to
safeguard their integrity at this
sensitive moment
rob powell sky news in westminster